Marcus are you an employee a freelancer
or a business owner I'm all of those
things actually I am an employee of
james-lange time who is also my investor
and producing partner and white were
avid entertainment so I'm a business
owner with him because we only have
business together and I'm a freelancer
in the sense that i make my own films so
I'm all three okay did you always think
of yourself and that light no not at all
not at all i want to do any of this but
give me this one to be an actor i just
want to show up on set like you know
drink fancy water and say words that's
all I ever ones do but you know in order
to do that sometimes you got to do some
other stuff so I got into writing
because I got frustrated as an actor and
I want to learn more about how the
business worked and I got into directing
purely out of necessity pure necessity I
had a location that was offered to me to
shoot in for free to do a short and what
the hell was it's called Bank of Venice
it's a restaurant in Venice California
which is town I love and Thomas Elliot
was a friend he's the owner he was a
friend of my buddy Jason Teague and I
had asked Jason if he could ask Tom if I
could shoot in bank of Venice during
their off hours and i was putting this
short together for nothing and jason
asked Tom and I talked Tom Tom was like
weak shut down you can shoot you can be
there till about five in the morning and
you don't have to pay me like okay great
awesome but I my director at the time
wasn't able to make that the time frame
she was out of town at the time and I
needed to take advantage of this
opportunity so I i told her i was just
going to do it and hope for the best and
it's unfortunate I really did want to
work person amazing but I just it was in
front of me I had to take it and I took
it that's how I shot my first short yes
as a director that's crazy
you